représentant de l'union européenne pour
les affaires étrangères josep borrell a
convoqué un conseil des affaires
étrangères extraordinaire ce vendredi il
a invité les ministres européens des
affaires étrangères ainsi que le
canadien l'ukrainien et le secrétaire
d'état américain anthony blinken les
précisions de notre correspondant jean
jacques guéry à bruxelles
et bien la réunion de l'otan on l'entend
du tout à l'heure avec les propos du
secrétaire général jens stoltenberg
avant le début de la réunion puis avec
ceux dont tony blinken le chef de la
diplomatie américaine qui a pris la
parole ensuite il faut réussir à
préserver et à sauvegarder l'unité de
l'alliance atlantique dans cette grave
crise qui ébranle le monde depuis jeudi
dernier d'une manière ou d'une autre ce
sont tous les alliés qui l ukraine
insisté anthony blinken par la voix de
son secrétaire général de l'otan a à
nouveau condamné les attaques sur les
civils et celle qui a touché une
centrale nucléaire ukrainienne la nuit
dernière cela démontre l'inconscience de
cette guerre et l'importance de la voir
prendre fin l'importance aussi de voir
la russie retirer toutes ses troupes
voilà ce qu'il a dit et puis l'enjeu on
l'a bien senti c'est aussi de répondre
au discours de vladimir poutine
d'insister sur le fait que l'otan n'est
pas une menace pour la russie on ne veut
pas la guerre contre la russie on ne
cherche pas la guerre nous avons
augmenté notre présence dans l'est de
l'europe mais il s'agit d'une présence
défensive ainsi répété jens stoltenberg
et cela même s'il faut rester prudent ça
laisse à penser qu'aucune décision
d'importance ne sera prise ce matin à
l'otan on a beaucoup évoqué ces derniers
jours l'imposition d'une zone
d'exclusion aérienne au-dessus du cren
les no fly zone en anglais bien cette
idée devrait être rejetée en droit
international nous confiait une source
diplomatique
c'est considéré comme une mesure
offensive une mesure de belligérance et
ça et bien effectivement l'alliance ne
veut surtout pas il faut plutôt faire
profil bas rappelait que l'otan n'est
pas une menace l'idée c'est de ne pas
tomber dans ce piège russe qui est de
vouloir impliquer l'otan nous confiait
cette même source diplomatique bref la
réunion de ce matin est plutôt un point
de situation est l'occasion de montrer
avec la présence d' anthony blinken que
les membres de l'alliance sont mobilisés
et unis ensuite les ministres des
affaires étrangères de l'union
européenne se retrouveront pour une
deuxième réunion cette fois ci sous
l'égide de l'union il s'agira d'un tour
de table d'éventuelles nouvelles
sanctions européennes contre la russie
sont dans les tuyaux d'ailleurs
interrogé tout à l'heure lors de son
arrivée au siège de l'otan à propos des
importations européennes de gaz et de
pétrole russe le chef de la diplomatie
de l'ue aux jo d'abord elle n'a rien
exclu vous avez pu constater que tout
était sur la table car certaines mesures
auxquelles personne ne s'attendait ont
été prises tout reste donc sur la table